so do you think you're a misogynist
absolutely not I'm not a misogynist on
any level this is one of those buzzwords
they throw it and they just throw at
people randomly homophobic races
misogynistics throw it out at people
what is your view of women I'm a realist
what's your real view of women I
absolutely not only love women I adore
women I have good relationships with
women not a single woman has come up to
me on the street since I've been
canceled not a single one has said
anything negative every single one of
them has said positive things you're a
traditional male I wish more men were
like you you understand your masculine
roles you understand what you're
supposed to do you understand you're
supposed to protect women you're exactly
the kind of man I'd be looking for I've
never had a negative interaction with a
female ever since I've been dubbed the
biggest massages where is the please
please let me finish I'm sorry sorry
Pierce also there's not been a single
woman who's accused me of a crime not
single woman's accused me of rape not
single woman's come out and said
anything from my entire past of 36 years
I've done anything wrong ever anybody
else with my level of Fame any football
or any other movie star at least has
people who've come out and accuse them
of rape XYZ I have no woman who's come
out and ever said I've hurt her no woman
has come out and ever said I've done
damage to her or been horrible to her
everybody who ever interacted with me
has said I've been a nice person all of
them his